we're in  heaven let's get a move on  shot him man put your hands up do it now  welcome to the world we're gonna get you  back on your feet I just want to make  things right with Beth and Lindsay Frank  oh my gosh you're so big  do you have anything you're really good  at not really what about picking locks  mom told me you were the best  foreign  the man I work for he won't let me go  and he's still hurting me after Kevin  died there was no one there to stop it I  wish I never brought him there that  night I need money to start a new life  and you'll have made it up to me  are you out of your mind  oh her not like that  another mistake and you're done  watch your six out there fellas  Beth they took her  we have to go to the police now  you find her  before they find you  gotta handle this on my own  throw that gun over here  foreign  [Music]